WITHIN THE ORGANIZATION.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, GREAT
WORK.
AMI HORWITZ, THANK YOU FOR
SHARING WITH US.
JOINING US NOW, FORMER
PROSECUTOR, PER CONGRESSMAN,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, TREY
GOWDY.
MAYBE I’M A LITTLE
OLD-FASHIONED, YOU DON’T LIKE LE
ANARCHISTS TAKE OVER CITIES AND
THE CONGRESSMAN OR I GUESS
THAT’S AN INSULT AT THIS POINT
IN YOUR LIFE, FELLOW COLLEAGUE
AT FOX.
IF YOU DON’T STOP IT IT’S GOING
TO GET WORSE OUT OF THE GOVERNOR
THAT WON’T DO A THING AND THE
MAYOR IS BASICALLY AIDING AND
ABETTING IN ALL OF THIS.
THE PRESIDENT OFFERS EVERY DAY.
WHEN YOU’RE READY I WILL HELP
YOU, WHATEVER HELP YOU NEED.
NO, THIS DOESN’T END WELL AS I
SEE IT.
>> I THINK THE POLICE IN SEATTLE
RETREATED, THEY SURRENDERED,
THEY ABANDONED THE POLICE
PRECINCT SO IF THESE PROTESTERS
ARE REALLY PEACEFUL I DON’T KNOW
WHY THE POLICE FELT THAT THEY
WERE IN DANGER OR FEARED FOR
THEIR SAFETY AND HAD TO RETREAT.
THE WAY I LOOK AT THE WORLD,
THERE ARE MOSTLY GOOD COPS AND A
FEW BAD.
THERE MAY BE MANY PEACEFUL
PROTESTERS BUT A FEW BAD.
I THINK WE ARE BETTER OFF IN
SOCIETY IF WE INDIVIDUALIZE IT,
IF YOU’RE GOING TO DESTROY OTHER
PEOPLES PROPERTY AND BREAK LAWS,
YOU SHOULD BE ARRESTED.
I DON’T CARE WHAT CITY YOU’RE
IN, IF YOU’RE A BAD COP YOU
SHOULD BE PROSECUTED, IF YOU’RE
A BAD PROTESTER THAT BREAKS THE
LAW YOU SHOULD BE PROSECUTED
ALSO.
>> Sean: OKAY, I DON’T THINK
IT’S HARD TO DO,
CONSTITUTIONALLY, AG BARR ADMITS
THAT PRESIDENT HAS THE RIGHT,
AUTHORITY CONSTITUTIONALLY TO GO
IN AND DO IT BUT IT’S REALLY THE
JOB OF THE GOVERNOR, THE JOB OF
THE MAYOR.
IF IT GETS TO A POINT WHERE IT’S
UNTENABLE THE PRESIDENT WILL
HAVE NO OTHER CHOICE, WHEN THAT
MOMENT HAPPENS I ASSUME IT WILL
BE TRANSPARENT AND OBVIOUS BUT
WHY WOULD THEY ALLOW THIS TO
HAPPEN, WHAT ABOUT THE BUSINESS
OWNERS?
THE HOMEOWNERS THAT SEE THEIR
WHOLE LIVES UPENDED, WHERE IS
THERE FREEDOM AND PROTECTION?
>> IT BAFFLES ME, I’M FROM A
STATE WHERE THE TOP PRIORITIES
ARE EDUCATION AND PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND I JUST ASSUME THAT’S TRUE
EVERYWHERE, PEOPLE WANT TO BE
SAFE AND THEY WANT THEIR KIDS TO
BE ADEQUATELY EDUCATED, MOST
CRIME STAYS LOCAL, THE FEDS
DON’T GET INVOLVED IN 99% OF
CRIME SO I THINK THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD USE FEDERAL POWER ONLY IF
COMMERCE IS IMPACTED, ONLY IF
THE ABILITY TO TRAVEL IS